at the Cannes Film Festival artificial
intelligence is taking center stage in
the new Indiana Jones film AI has
de-aged eight-year-old Harrison Ford by
35 years achieved by combing through
decades-old footage of Ford proving
there are no relics sorry it's just a
trick unless it's it's supported by
story if it's not honest and it's not
real I mean emotionally real and and so
I think it was used very go for it I'm
very happy with it but I don't look back
and say I wish I was that guy AI has
long been a source of inspiration for
Cinema from Metropolis to The Matrix the
cult dystopian film in which AI has
created a simulated world
but it's behind the camera where AI will
now influence what we see in Cinemas
Hollywood studios are already investing
in AI to inform on release dates
marketing and distribution strategies
while in the Cannes Film Market
producers seeking funds A putting their
script through an algorithm to determine
return on investment Captain Samantha
Miller very the AI program has analyzed
400 000 film scripts to understand the
most popular story lines predict
audience reaction and potential Revenue
we have content tools casting tools
Financial forecast tool demographics
tools but I guess one thing that that
people are always curious about the
financial predictions what's the
accuracy for financial predictions so we
measure green lighting accuracy which is
around 80 percent so 80 percent of times
it finds the film that will be
successful which is superior to the
industry industry trap recording because
Independent Producers are concerned
purely using AI will decrease the
overall quality of films and if you look
at a lot of streaming services all right
and the reason why all their content no
matter what language it's in is all the
same way is because it hits the
algorithm's points it takes away a
little the agency out of the filmmaker's
hands if we strike a balance between
allowing that human initiative and that
human genius to shine through and giving
investors a return on their investment
well you know again there has to be a
happy balance AI will transform visual
effects far beyond de-aging cutting time
resources and ultimately costs but the
industry is mindful that while
algorithms can create scripts generate
new worlds and make predictions they may
lack the unique perspective and
emotional depth that comes from Human
creativity Charlie Angela Al Jazeera